[Music]
to be able to be doing science while
you're out there insert for it
surfing down the face of the wait it's
just such a fleeting moment it's
incredible to actually be able to do it
smart Finn is a surfboard fit you clip
it on the bottom of your board you go
out for your surf session it has
technology that measures ocean pH
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we had detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they are just not
deployed at the coast bingo
smart fin can fill that gap collecting
oceanic data is a very time-consuming
expensive process this is like you just
need to know how to surf the data moves
from your fin to your phone via
bluetooth and then from your phone it
goes up to our servers where
everything's processed I had to develop
sensors that don't affect the surfboard
nobody's going to surf a fin that is not
a standard foil aside from that LED
right there is blinking that tells you
that there's like some sort of
technology there you wouldn't know the
difference so we've got a test tank set
up now and we're just trying to look at
the precision and accuracy of the
instrument itself things are looking
pretty promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales I mean the fact
that you can go out and surf and
contribute to understanding what's
actually happening out there is
incredible I'm not a surfer I know
nothing about surfing I know I look like
a surfer but um I'm not surfers are very
influential and care deeply about the
environment and want to be talking about
it
so smartphone is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way c-sections are
the most common major surgery performed
on human beings over basically one
generation of moms the c-section rate
has gone up at 500% problem is that your
number one risk for having a c-section
might be which hospital you go to that's
what wakes me up in the morning
[Music]
I'm Neel Shah and obstetrician over at
Beth Israel Deaconess Medical Center I'm
an assistant professor at Harvard
Medical School and I'm part of the core
faculty here at Ariadne labs a lot of
people don't realize the full magnitude
of the problem with c-sections
basically in the late 1960s early 1970s
c-section rates were about 5% and then
all of a sudden c-section rate starts to
skyrocket not just increased but
skyrocket so before the end of the
century a c-section rate goes up to one
and three and we don't really have a
great idea why this is happening
as a surgeon myself it's hard to believe
that one in three human beings needs a
major surgery to be born but that's sort
of where we are right now and the
consequences are significant so things
like severe infection hemorrhage organ
injury in addition to five billion
dollars of spending annually we're
talking something like 20,000 major
avoidable surgical complications were
seeing from c-sections we didn't need to
do in the first place
I was really puzzled when I first
started this job thinking like what can
we possibly do about this
epidemiologists economists policymakers
lots of people have been thinking about
this for a long time the clue for me was
the fact that across-country c-section
rates vary from 7 percent to 70 percent
by hospital
if Hospital performance is so uneven and
it's not explained by patient risk for
patient preference that means the
hospital itself could be a risk factor
all of our projects right now are
actually trying to figure out what makes
hospital a different from hospital B
[Music]
what we've seen is that oftentimes the
labor floors and kind of like a almost
forgotten about corner and it just
doesn't get a lot of investment or
attention from the hospital when we
visit a bunch of different hospitals who
realize that they're laid out very
differently and that might matter for
example there are no rules for how many
labor floor rooms you should have based
on the amount of patients that you see
the place that does twice as many
deliveries also does way more c-sections
the only way that's possible is if
they're moving people through much
faster almost all labor floors seem
really tight on resources so the idea is
when you have a huge surge in patient
volume how do you flexibly recruit more
rooms how do you bring in more staff you
report c-section rates back to your
doctors look I have no idea what my
c-section rate is until somebody tells
me you know we're testing this
hypothesis that management matters in
childbirth just the way it matters in
every other industry we're starting to
parse differences among c-section so
rather than looking at all c-sections
altogether we're trying to just take the
lowest risk women can focus on their
c-section rate
this'n needs to start to do that two
things happen insurance companies start
to pay attention and then just women
start to pay attention and I actually
think this is an area where women's
views on this are probably going to be
the driving force behind the change
there's really no other moment in
people's life where they're so
discerning as when they become pregnant
[Music]
it's Hamburg Germany
the year is 1669 inside of a basement
laboratory Alchemist Henning brand is
boiling gallons of urine to create the
fabled Philosopher's Stone unbeknownst
to him the urine is about to lead to a
truly world altering discovery during
the Middle Ages the Philosopher's Stone
was the coveted discovery because it was
believed it could turn ordinary metal to
gold in his quest to find it brand
accumulated over 1,500 gallons of urine
he thought that by purifying the waste
the Philosopher's Stone would
materialize in what was left the process
went like this one age the urine until
an intense odour billows out of the
samples to boil the urine until a white
paste materializes three place the
heated paste in a retort for gold will
then drip out of the wait what okay so
it wasn't gold that emerged but a solid
white substance that glowed in the dark
this was big this was bigger than big
his discovery was gonna change the world
brand had discovered phosphorus one of
the building blocks of life making him
the first person to ever discover a
chemical element but the thing was he
had no idea he believed he had found a
glowing Philosopher's Stone and named
the substance phosphorus meaning bringer
of light brand kept his discovery a
secret until he eventually sold his
process to other scientists it wasn't
until after his death that he was given
credit for discovering phosphorus all by
boiling urine in his basement laboratory
[Music]
when a patient first comes to our office
they feel a little self-conscious about
the way they look or they don't want to
look people I die people always think
I'm just doing this for cosmetic reasons
but actually it's the restoration of a
person I'm an ocularist that is someone
that fits and fabricates artificial eyes
for people during the surgery to remove
your eye
the doctors place an implant in the
muscle cone so we fit a concave convex
shape that sits like a contact lens on
the implant it is an art form we do
everything by hand first we take an
impression this gives us an imprint of
these act structures behind the eyelids
painting is very challenging everything
starts from a black disc and everything
is painted on top of that it's very
difficult to match the iris color no two
people have the same color so we'll sit
there with a paintbrush and we'll paint
different structures dots dashes
striations overlay that with different
hues or different saturations of color
to give it the three-dimensional effect
that we see in people's natural eyes
part of what makes it look natural is to
have the sparkle in your eye we do that
with fine polishing and fine tuning the
curves of the artificial eye the part I
most like about fabricating a prosthesis
is when I finished it and I look at it
and I see the illusion that I've just
created when somebody loses their eye
sometimes they feel like they've lost
part of their self being we make them
feel whole again and confident to take
on the world
I believe that the word cold cases is
wrong because it could be perhaps
something that's in a drawer somewhere
in an office but their family's hasn't
forgotten them and they're still looking
for them and I just want to do my best
to help when authorities have failed to
identify the remains of a body there is
very little hope of closure for these
john and jane doe's but every year an
enterprising studio of student artists
use their knowledge of the human form to
try and breathe life into these cold
cases here we're doing a forensic
reconstruction of a real case trying to
get it as close as he used to look like
when he was alive so we can identify him
we are given a 3d print not the real
skull we use it as a framework so we can
reconstruct the anatomy of the
individual first we start adding the
muscles on the framework given by the
bone and then we try to complete those
things that are not so clear like the
ear or the mouth right now I'm working
on Caucasian white man between 40 to 60
years old there are indications that he
lost his teeth when he was alive and his
bones are telling me all that these
lifelike models are provided to
authorities often reinvigorating
investigations and bringing much-needed
closure to loved ones after my first
experience last year I was lucky enough
that the person was identified and I got
this beautiful letter from the family
members saying thank you
when we see this process it feels almost
like you resuscitating someone but I
know that beyond that where your
resuscitating is the life of those
families that are looking for this
person
[Music]